bonjour à tous hier après midi les
sénateurs ont auditionné henri proglio
le président d'edf
lors de cette rencontre deux points ont
été abordés l'organisation de la filière
nucléaire française mais aussi la mise
en oeuvre de la loi nome cette loi nome
prévoit une nouvelle organisation du
marché de l'électricité c'est une
obligation pour la france qui doit
adapter les directives européennes en la
matière edf le géant français est le
premier visé par cette loi
il va devoir céder à prix coûtant un
quart de sa production nucléaire à ses
concurrents tels que poweo ou encore
direct energie par ailleurs autre
évolution sensible cette évolution
devrait avoir un impact sur les prix
non seulement pour les consommateurs
mais aussi pour l'industrie tout de
suite donc retour à l'audition d'hier
après midi très bonne édition bien
mesdames messieurs chers collègues
merci de votre présence je voulais en
votre nom
accueillir le président proglio qui est
le président-directeur général
d'electricité de france vous dire ce
président nom de mes collègues combien
nous est agréable de vous recevoir dans
le cadre de cette audition de la
commission de l'économie du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire auquel ont
été invités les sénatrices et sénateurs
du mans membre du groupe d'études sur
l'énergie
le dernier souvenir que nous avons de
vous c'est au moment où vous étiez
candidat à cette présidence et où les
commissions compétentes de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat ont dû
donner leur avis et puis bien bien sûr
sur la loi nome je vois que certains
sénateurs
suivent de très près tout ce qui
concerne l'énergie et en particulier
l'électricité
donc c'est le président simplement je
vais vous donner la parole pour que vous
nous parliez de votre stratégie ddf sur
le territoire national et bien sûr que
vous nous parliez de la stratégie de
votre groupe à l'international
voilà ce président c'est pour s'exciter
sur l'unique ce sera aussi plus souvent
on peut mais les coupes sont allés sans
problème
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est un
randonneur de retrouver aujourd'hui dans
cette formation et qui voit j'avais eu
l'honneur de vous rencontrer
collectivement au qu au moment de ma
présentation aux fonctions dès
aujourd'hui et puis à l'occasion de de
la loire de la loi nome dans l'histoire
n'est pas définitivement écrite on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
c'est joël ainsi comme dit le président
c'est une histoire sans cesse renouvelé
j'avais prévu de vous nous faire un bon
pot liminaire sur sur la stratégie
industrielle particulièrement adaptée au
nucléaire elle c'était le sujet de mon
propos mais je suis tout à fait disposé
à l'élargir à la stratégie d'edf ce que
je ferais si l'ebook souhaitait très
rapidement en quelques mots tout de
suite et puis de répondre à toutes vos
questions sur la stratégie d'edf edf est
un groupe qui au nom de ses 50 ans
d'histoire a construit un leadership
mondial dans son domaine de compétence
qui est celui de la gestion de service
électrique edf est d'abord un opérateur
de service public
fier de ses racines de cette
caractéristique et qui s'est développé
au fond dans l'ensemble des composantes
du système du métier de l'énergie
électrique en particulier puisque
c'était sa vocation originelle
on élargit actuellement à d'autres
secteurs d'activités de l'énergie bien
entendu premier premier acteur mondial
corps à la fois d'une expérience acquise
fort de son expertise fort de ses
traditions fort des qualités humaines
qu'elle a su intégrer fort ses ambitions
mais cette ambition est désormais
clairement et délibérément international
jeu depuis un an presque jour pour jour
puisque j'ai rejoint le groupe le 25
novembre 2009 déjà essayé d'identifier
et de structurer une stratégie qui se
veut professionnel et industriels et que
je réserverai de la manière simple qui
ré suivante d'abord les piliers du
groupe doivent être constituées autour
des grands axes industrielle de
l'expertisé du groupe et cette expertise
elle tient à trois grands domaines
d'activité qui sont l'amont du cycle
c'est à dire en fait la production sous
toutes ses formes qu'il s'agisse du
nucléaire qu'ils s'agissent de
l'hydraulique qu'il s'agit du thermique
qu'il s'agit d'une renouvelables à man u
cycle et j'ai donc décidé
d'identifier clairement ce pilier et
d'en faire un métier mondiale dans l'
expertise doit rayonner tout autour du
monde et dont le savoir faire à vocation
être clairement l'international je n'ai
confier la responsabilité avait
machenaud qui est ici derrière moi qui
est le patron de la production et qui
groupe qui regroupe donc l'ensemble des
composantes du groupe et notamment la
filière nucléaire le deuxième de ses
piliers
c'est l'aval du cycle beaucoup moins
connu en tout cas à l'international -
identifier c'est à dire qu'on peut ce
qui s'appelle dans le jargon interne de
la maison edf l'optimisation comment à
partir d'infrastructure existants de
production de transport de distribution
est-ce qu'on optimise l'ensemble de ses
infrastructures très lourdement
capitalistique pour faire en sorte de
10,2 d'optimiser des investissements
nécessaire de faire en sorte d'optimiser
le service à partie des infrastructures
existantes
s'y ajoutent le commerce vers la gestion
des services clients et puis le trading
c'est à dire ouf on l'optimisation de
l'alimentation en matière première c'est
l'aval du cycle et cette arête du cycle
il est
s'y ajoute une quatrième composante
assez étrange pour
si on ne prend pas je dirai clairement
la mesure de son importance et la
tarification la gestion des tarifs
comment faire en sorte que à iso
infrastructures de production de
distribution et de transport à
équivalence de capacité de 2,2 de
l'outil est ce qu'on permet l'accès à
tous au travers d'une gestion tarifaire
intelligente ou adapté donc
l'accessibilité d'un service public
essentiel qui est l'électricité cette
gestion tarifaire à laquelle vous êtes
très accoutumée que les français
perçoivent moyennement bien parce
qu'elle est assez complexe et 1,1 des
éléments formidablement important de
l'accessibilité du service et d'acadie
de services offerts et c'est donc une
véritable expertise qui a développé le
groupe cours des 50 dernières années
c'est une expertise rare qui est souvent
sollicité par beaucoup de pays à
l'international
donc l'aval du cycle et puis entre les
deux les réseaux transport et
distribution et ses réseaux devient de
plus en plus sophistiquées au point
qu'on les appelle les réseaux
intelligents
non pas que les réseaux d'hyères et est
idiot mais enfin ceux d'aujourd'hui on a
intégré une valeur ajoutée
supplémentaire qui est la dimension des
nouvelles technologies dans
l'interactivité des régions troisième
pilier industriel du groupe et donc
c'est sur ces trois piliers que reposent
les trois grands axes de développement
du groupe qui ont vocation à être
internationaux soit de façon univoque
c'est à dire qu'on peut on peut
travailler à l'international dans
l'amont du cycle on peut travailler à
l'intérieur d'un l'aval du cycle on peut
travailler à l'international dans les
réseaux on peut tout autant connecter
l'ensemble pour créer le service intégré
une efficacité absolue et qui est je
crois à l'idéal de ce qu'on peut offrir
comme système mais les uns et des autres
ont chacun chacune de ses composantes
chacun de ses piliers a vocation à avoir
une dimension internationale et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous ai dit que
j'avais confié l'amont du cycle de
production
un grand professionnel un grand
industriel est quelqu'un qui avait une
grande
habitude de l'international pour avoir
passé l'essentiel de sa vie
professionnelle à défendre les couleurs
de la france
ailleurs et notamment en chine où il a
passé quinze 15 ans un peu près il est
encore temps partiel enfin il est ici
que j'ai confié l'aval du cycle donc
l'optimisation de commerce à un grand
professionnel si pierre lederer qui a
lui passé onze ans de sa vie construire
la dimension de de l'énergie dans ces
nouvelles composantes en allemagne et
j'ai confié les réseaux la distribution
en tout cas à michel béland et qui est
également un grand professionnel
trois piliers trois dimensions
internationales une vision ambitieuse du
développement international du groupe
et bien sûr de l'optimisation du service
dans notre pays au travers des activités
de production de distribution qui ont de
l'activité concessive et des activités
d'optimisation de trading et de et du
commerce
j'aurai l'occasion si vous le souhaitez
de revenir ensuite sur sur cette
dimension internationale or les la
vocation internationale du groupe est
absolument évident c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui concevoir edf comme
étant un groupe de dimension
le leader mondial sans avoir la
perspective de porter la conquête
internationale la priorité
sans jamais oublier ni nos origines ni
les ambitions légitimes dont notre
france et revendique les mérites c'est à
dire au fond le meilleur service et
qu'ils soient dans le domaine de
l'électricité au service de la nation
en ce qui concerne le rayonnement
international
évidemment il faudra rentrer un peu plus
si vous le souhaitez dans l'analyse et
la projection parce qu'évidemment
l'ambition de l'amont du cycle c'est à
dire la conception construction d'unités
de production n'a pas la même ne
mémorisons géographique que la gestion
de réseaux distribution et par là même
ne se superposent pas exactement avec
les développements prévisible du groupe
en tout cas à court terme dans le
domaine des services de laval pour
autant l'international constitue déjà
45% du chiffre d'affaires du groupe a
vocation à être totalement dominant dans
les trois à cinq ans qui lie en chiffre
d'affaires et un résultat nous sommes
aujourd'hui très présent en europe
notamment évidemment en dehors de la
france
en grande bretagne où nous sommes le
premier opérateur britannique en italie
où nous sommes le deuxième opérateur en
europe centrale
nous étions en allemagne avant la
récente évolution que don sur laquelle
je suis tout à fait disposé à revenir et
nous avons vocation à considérer le
territoire européen comme le marché
domestique nous sommes le deuxième
opérateur belge était enfin on pourra
venir plus dans le détail sont présents
en suisse
encore une fois l'europe c'est le marché
domestique de nous sommes également très
présent l'asie en asie avec une forte
présence en chine devant accompagner la
construction de producteurs chinois
depuis maintenant 20 ans et nous sommes
les partenaires du programme nucléaire
chinois qui est le plus grand problème
nucléaire en cours de construction dans
le monde
nous sommes présents avec du nord comme
vous le savez et nous avons une présence
qui se confirme au moyen-orient avec des
développements prévus
en afrique et dans d'autres régions
géographiques y compris la maladie voilà
ce que la présence actuelle mais encore
une fois c'est une vie en très très
rapide je reviens du laos où nous avons
inauguré la semaine dernière le barrage
de nam theun qui est probablement la
plus belle réalisation en matière
d'hydroélectricité qui existe
actuellement dans le monde grands
barrages 1300 mégawatts de production
électrique qui à lui tout seul
représente un taux de croissance du pib
du la hausse de 3% prévus dès l'année
c'est je pense la plus belle référence
en matière de développement durable qui
puisse exister actuellement en matière
énergétique dans le monde mais sans
doute
aurez vous l'occasion en soin de visiter
soin de poser toutes les questions que
vous souhaitez à cet égard je reviens
sur le sujet auquel je voulais je
voulais vous dire quelques matières
nucléaires avant de évidemment me prêter
à vos questions
edf et comme je viens de le dire le
premier exploitant nucléaire au monde et
de très loin
on essaie bien sûr mais on oublie à quel
point cette position est exceptionnel
puisque notre capacité nucléaire
principalement en france et au royaume
uni représente 74 gigawatts soit près de
trois fois celle du deuxième expert
mondial quelle ruse roos énergie atom
cinq fois celle du premier exploitant
nucléaire américain ou encore plus près
de nous douze fois celle du belge
electrabel filiale de gdf suez c'est
cela qui fait que nous sommes attendus
est reconnue partout dans le monde sur
la filière pressurisés et sur le seul
territoire français
nous disposons d'un retour d'expérience
d'exploitation de 1450 année réacteurs
aucun autre acteur dans le monde ne
dispose d'une telle expérience est bien
évidemment pas les constructeurs et
daphné pas seulement exploitants il est
aussi le concepteur de six centrales
pourtant l'émission d'architecte
ensemblier son aise son ingénierie qu'on
soit parce les contrats de fabrication
supervise le montage sur site
cette complémentarité entre
exploitations engine
et tout à fait essentiel aller au
fondement même de notre stratégie
elle est au coeur du succès historique
du nucléaire français elle seule permet
de maîtriser pleinement la complexité de
la technologie du nucléaire
ou pour dire les choses plus simplement
en exploite bien ce que l'on a construit
et on construit mieux à partir de ce
qu'on a déjà exploité
c'est ainsi par exemple que nous avons
construit nos 58 réacteurs ou tranche
pwr en france palier après palier
tranche après tranche en capitalisant à
chaque fois sur le retour d'expérience
de la construction puis de
l'exploitation
c'est aussi comme cela qu edf a procédé
pour ses premiers développement
nucléaire à l'international de la
première tranche nucléaire construite en
chine à daya bay à la fin des années 80
qui était l'exacte réplique de la
dernière et plus abouti de notre ange de
900 mégawatts celle de gravelines 6 près
de dunkerque
c'est ainsi que procède aujourd'hui les
trois autres grandes industries
nucléaires subsistant dans le monde
les coréens les russes et les chinois
et c'est donc ainsi qu'il nous faut
poursuivre aujourd'hui notre
développement à l'échelle internationale
entendons-nous les coréens les russes et
les six n'ont pas besoin de nous pour
construire des centrales nucléaires chez
eux ou dans le monde
il dispose d'une ingénierie performante
d'un tissu industriel de marché sans
aucune mesure avec les marchés
occidentaux au moins pour la chine de
capitaux employés pour certains d'entre
eux et la chine en particulier
la seule chose dont ne disposent pas
encore la corée et la chine
c'est justement le retour d'expérience
de l'exploitation il se trouve qu edf
dispose de cet atout considérable du
moins sur la filière à eau pressurisée
si la raison pour laquelle edf a
vocation à injecter son retour
d'expérience dans les programmes
nucléaires ou le groupe est attendu et
en contrepartie enrichir son propre
retour d'expérience de construction puis
l'exploitation à partir des projets qui
constituent le nucléaire de demain
ce nouveau retour d'expérience est
essentiel pour prétendre continuer à
être un acteur de référence dans le
monde
l'objectif d'edf et de l'industrie
francs
c'est cependant bien sûr consisté à
inonder le marché du nucléaire mondial
nous n'avons ni la capacité financière
ni la capitale industrielle
edf n'a pas les moyens de financer ses
propres investissements en france
jour-là besoin d'y revenir
ni areva la capacité de remplacer
l'ensemble de nos générateurs de vapeur
sur le parc existant
comment edf pourrait-il alors financer
les 100 à 200 milliards d'euros du
programme nucléaire mondial où arrive à
construire les équipements
correspondants
alors soyons réalistes sur une
cinquantaine de réacteurs nucléaires en
construction dans le monde
d'ailleurs pour l'essentiel en asie en
russie la france n'est partie prenante
d'un 4 e p r au quillio tôt flamanville
3 et les deux tranches de taishan en
chine
ainsi notre proposition était différente
adaptée et adaptable à la diversité des
situations d'accompagner les pays et les
acteurs qui font le choix du nucléaire
et qui bien sûr le fond dans le cadre
des organisations et un d'art
internationaux au travers d'un système
d'alliances modulable notre rôle doit
être en effet avant tout industriel
notre vocation n'est pas d'apporter des
capitaux que d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas
mais d'apporter notre expérience notre
expertise
s'agissant du financement la france et
l'europe devraient me semble t'il
réfléchir à la constitution d'organes de
financement adaptées à la construction
du nucléaire dans le monde les
américains savent ceux de tels outils
quand il s'agit d'exporter leur propre
industrie nous avons réussi à emprunter
des capitaux chinois pour le temps du
chantier de taishan
mais cela constitue à l'évidence une
exception et le financement bancaire
d'un projet nucléaire
une difficulté majeure pourquoi ne pas y
réfléchir et imaginé un dispositif
financier capable d'appuyer d'un
transfert nucléaire pour camper pour
accompagner les pays et des acteurs qui
font le choix du nucléaire aujourd'hui
pour apporter notre expérience
industrielle à d'autres électriciens
nous pouvons endossé par exemple le rôle
d'assistant à maîtrise d ouvrage comme
nous l'avons fait en chine à daya bay ce
rôle doit être initiée très en amont des
projets
nous pouvons alors dans la phase de pré
faisabilité apporter du conseil sur des
sujets aussi variés que le cadre
réglementaire permettant de sécuriser un
investisseur et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes les sites pouvant héberger une
centrale nucléaire
les conditions socio-économiques de son
acceptation locale la sécurisation de la
déconstruction et du stockage ultime de
ces déchets son intégration dans le
réseau électrique
la qualification de ses ressources
humaines etc notre connaissance et celle
de l'exploitant et de l'investisseur
dans le don ne dispose aucun
constructeur nous jouons ce rôle en
italie avec enel en pologne avec pge
après avoir joué dans une moindre mesure
ce même rôle ô ô unis ce rôle de
premiers contacts ou deux premiers
partenaires nous permet de gagner la
confiance de nos interlocuteurs pour les
accompagner ensuite il ya le partenariat
se concrétise dans la conduite d'un vrai
projet nucléaire
ce positionnement d'assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvragé permet d'amener nos
partenaires de l'industrie nucléaire
française dans l'esprit par exemple
d'une coopération
mais ce sera nécessairement du cas par
cas car l'équipe française doit être
adaptée à chaque situation
immergé dans un réseau d'alliances
internationales plus large et concilier
au droit de la concurrence
chaque pays et chaque acteur à ses
propres intérêts dans le développement
d'une industrie rien panne italie nous
avons des accords avec enel le
développement d'une industrie militaire
italienne fait partie intégrante du
programme du gouvernement italien
des accords ont donc été signée dans ce
sens entrée de f arriva en salle d'eau
et enel de fait cette stratégie intègre
pleinement areva alstom et l'ensemble
des pme qui ont participé au
développement du programme nucléaire
français
de même que l'ensemble des constructeurs
souvent français ou européens avec
lesquels nous avons construit et nous
entretenons actuellement le parc
français dans notre logique industrielle
en effet nous avons tout intérêt à
travailler avec le constructeur
historique de nos réacteurs
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons tirer
ensemble le meilleur parti de nos
expériences
et de nos synergies les positionnements
d'edf et d'areva sont en effet
complémentaire des fêtes a mené
l'électricien quelques années des
centaines de milliards de kilowattheures
nucléaire à partir des centrales que
nous avons nous mêmes conçus par
dizaines en france
arriva est un fabricant de réacteurs est
un acteur de services autour du
combustible
le métier d'areva n'est pas de produire
de l'énergie pas plus que le nôtre est
de construire des réacteurs
ni de forger des cuves les industriels
qui réussissent dans nucléaires sont
ceux qui marie l'exploitation et
l'ingénieux de conception les risques de
construction sont telles qu'on
constructeur ne pas les assumer seule
chose renchérit considérablement son
offre edf a construit 58 tranches en
france sur des sites très différents les
uns des autres et accompagné avec succès
plusieurs pays dans le développement du
nucléaire comme la chine ou d'afrique du
sud actuellement edf à trois chantiers
en cours en france et en chine les
prépare ce qui ne l'est pas et en
angleterre et de penly en normandie
enfin la relation entre edf areva alstom
et les pme que nous proposons ne peut
être exclusive à la fois pour permettre
à ses équipementiers notamment arriva de
construire pour le compte de certains
opérateurs qui le souhaiteraient et pour
nous permettre aussi selon les
circonstances du triel de travailler
avec d'autres chaudiériste enfin
d'élargir notre connaissance du tissu
industriel
on pourrait imaginer par exemple que des
f aides à la rénovation d'un vr russe
comme edf a pu le faire dans le passé
cela ne compromet pas la capacité des
industriels français à saisir les
opportunités de faire valoir leur savoir
faire qui sur l'ensemble de la
fourniture d'une centrale ne manqueront
certainement pas de se présenter
nous disons seulement seulement que la
vocation d'edf est d'être le point
d'entrée naturelle avec les pays où
acteurs désireux de développer ou de
rénover centrales électronucléaires car
il apporte ce qui constitue la source
essentielle de l'industrie nucléaire
française
je les lis tout à l'heure le retour
d'expérience du plus grand parc électro
nucléaire du monde
s'agissant enfin des réacteurs la france
voir rapidement disposer d'une gamme de
réacteurs diversifiée permettant de
répondre aux différents besoins
you et préparant sur le très long terme
le renouvellement du parc français dans
des conditions optimales de sûreté et de
compétitivité
c'est ainsi que des f a choisi très
clairement d'abord de poursuivre
l'optimisation de pm en tirant le
premier retour d'expérience des
chantiers de flamanville 3 et de tai
shan et avec areva de celui de kyoto
par ailleurs il souhaite engager des
études ce développement d'un projet de
réacteurs de 1000 mégawatts
conçu à partir de l'expérience du parc
français de 900 mégawatts qui a été un
véritable succès enfin je ne voudrais
pas conclure mon propos sans dire un mot
du parc nucléaire français existant dans
ce débat sur le parc nucléaire
international très médiatisées où l'on
se plaît à évoquer l'échec d'abou dhabi
est les divergences d'intérêt entre edf
et areva
il est singulier de constater que l'on
oublie souvent le parent français les
difficultés qu'il traverse et le
financement dans ce parc a besoin dans
les années qui viennent alors que nous
interrogeant pour savoir qui portera le
drapeau à l'international on oublie que
sur nos arrières le parent français est
aujourd'hui dans une phase délicate
la majorité des trente joueurs
prochainement franchir le cap décisif
des trente ans qui dans une industrie
lourde comme la nôtre correspond à l'âge
des renouvellement des gros composants
c'est la période du grand carénage au
sens où de gros équipements comme les
générateurs de vapeur les alternateurs
les transformateurs peuvent être
renouvelés ce qu'ont déjà fait nos
homologues américains européens
nous avons pris du retard dans la
matière il n'y a pas d'impact sur la
sûreté bien entendu mais cela nous cause
de sévères avarie grève nos performances
et terni la référence française
il ya là et nous avons commencé depuis
un an et il travaille à une opportunité
considérable pour l'industrie française
chiffré à plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros sur les années qui
viennent soit bien plus que ce que peut
représenter le développement
international en notre industrie n'a pas
aujourd'hui la capacité de produire
l'ensemble de ses composants à l'échelle
de temps envisagé nous proposons pour le
parc existant de réinventer ce que nous
avons su faire lors de sa construction
une politique industrielle porteuses
avait d'investissement dans des
capacités dé production de recrutement
deux formations d'hommes et de femmes
encore faut-il en avoir les moyens
financiers il est essentiel que le prix
auquel la production nucléaire sera
cédée à des concurrents comme le niveau
des tarifs régulés au client final
couvre les coûts du nucléaire existant y
compris le remboursement et la
rémunération de l'investissement initial
et nous permettent ainsi de financer les
investissements à venir
mon propos n'est pas seulement
circonstancielle il est intrinsèque à
l'essence même du choix nucléaire très
capitalistique comme vous le savez si
les français prive le nucléaire
existante s'ajuste rentabilité dans sa
période d'âge mûr alors même qu'il doit
faire face à de nouveaux investissements
ils se comportent comme des prédateurs
et signe sur le long terme
le déclin de toute cette industrie en
conclusion pour le parc existant comme
pour le développement international le
nucléaire constitue aujourd'hui une
opportunité considérable et une chance
pour la france c'est de relancer
l'industrie une formation de haute
valeur ajoutée pour nos jeunes c'est de
faire bénéficier la france d'un outil de
production / non émetteur de gaz à effet
de serre
résistant conjoncture macro énergétique
mondiale
merci pour votre attention merci
monsieur présidente ce tour d'horizon
sur votre stratégie nationale
internationale
et puis bien sûr plus particulièrement
sur l'énergie d'origine nucléaire
j'ai pas être plus long j'ai donné la
parole à ladislas poniatowski qui
préside le groupe d'études énergie et
puis après j'ai déjà plusieurs
inscriptions alors celles et ceux qui
veulent s'inscrire relève la main
chaudement de tenir la main levée donc
la lys las merci monsieur le président
j'ai quatre questions je suis le rapide
monsieur le président merci pour votre
présentation une première question sur
la loi nome bien sûr c'est normal que je
vous pose des questions venu couper pas
vous avez fait sourire plusieurs de mes
collègues en disant que l'histoire
n'était pas définitivement écrite c'est
vrai et nous savons très bien ce qui
manque c'est notamment le prix vous
venez différents légion à l'instant même
lorsque nous vous avions entendu non
vous n'avez pas beaucoup le prix vous
venez de dire
vous vouliez voir ni dans le prix
lorsque vous avions entendu le 23 juin
dernier vous aviez été plus précis vous
aviez dit que un prix inférieur à 42
euros ne ferait pas la faire où en êtes
vous aujourd'hui
question subsidiaire sur la loi nome
nous avons mis dans la loi nome le
marché des capacités de production et
d'effacement
quel rôle pensez vous que edf peut jouer
sur ce marché les capacités de
production et d'effacement sujet qui
tient à coeur à certains nos
parlementaires deuxième question
l'allemagne
vous avez quitté un vos investissements
en allemagne
je vous ai bien lu comme pas mal de mes
collègues lorsque vous avez quittez vous
avez rajouté une petite phrase en disant
ça ne veut pas dire que edf ne
reviendrait pas en allemagne
ça veut dire quoi que vous ne reviendrez
que si vous seriez majoritaire dans une
société où autre chose troisième
question directement liée à votre
opération allemande
elle vous a quand même rapporté quelques
sous et je m'en réjouis pour votre
entreprise
ça a été présenté comme à la fois des
capacités de développement dans des
projets et j'imagine ça traite vous
venez d'évoquer et surtout de
désendettement alors pourquoi je dire
pour quel pour quelles priorités même à
une que vous n'avez pas évoqué on vous
avait bien on vous a bien entendu vos
projets de développement international
vos projets sur le parc nucléaire
français qu'il faudra renouveler
vous n'avez pas évoqué areva c'est un
sujet qui revient à l'ordre du jour
notamment sur la capitaliser la
capitalisation d'areva nous venons de
voir ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques
jours avec l'entrée dans le capital
d'areva du fonds d'investissement du
koweït est ce que ça fait partie
toujours de vos souhaits et de vos
projets dernière question monsieur le
président sur développement
international vous avez très
diplomatiquement précisé qu'en france il
y avait plusieurs grands acteurs sur
nucléaire
vous même bien sûr areva alstom et qu'
il faudrait je dirais prendre le
meilleur parti des expériences et
d'énergie des uns des autres dans le
rapport roussely
il ya quelque chose qui m'a gêné il est
bon pour vous en ce sens que le rapport
roussely a dit que c'est vous qui
devriez y est le chef de file partout le
pragmatisme de nous faisions preuve
auparavant c'est à dire de temps en
temps c'était vous qui étiez chef de
file et porte-drapeau dans d'autres
circonstances étaient areva était à
pragmatisme pas si mauvais que ça je
vais juste prendre deux exemples en
afrique du sud
je pense que si c'est areva qui est mis
en avant
nous ne gagnerons pas ce projet qui est
repartie à zéro alors que si c'est vous
nous avons des choses le gagner pour les
autres et simple l'électricien sud
africain veut partenariat avec
l'électricien français que vous êtes et
la renommée vous avez en inde
c'est pas le cas celle inverse je pense
que ce serait une erreur que ce soit
vous qui soyez le porte drapeau
compte tenu que vous fait peur à
l'électricien indien et que les indiens
veulent un partenariat avec areva et
donc je pragmatisme me plaît mais
j'aimerais beaucoup avoir votre avis
là-dessus
voilà monsieur le président mes quatre
questions oui merci ça va donner à
monsieur le président je vous propose
deux rapports de répondre au président
du groupe d'études et puis après il ya
une dizaine d'interventions le syded
bref sur l'album
tout a été dit en tout cas pas moi je ne
suis pas un zélateur de la loi nome je
reconnais que à partir d'un point
d'origine qui été cataclysmique
le parlement a très significativement
redresser
sujet au point d'arriver à un projet que
j'estime équilibré et qui se traduit
très schématiquement en matière de prix
en termes synthétique en disant
cohérence avec le tartam le tartam qui
était en 2009 et fait une valeur 2009 à
42 euros il est aujourd'hui entre notre
43 ans trois et demi de longues études
ont été faites les commissions
parlementaires se sont réunis nombre de
débats ont eu lieu et de démonstration
était faite qui ont conduit à cette
conclusion dire un industriel qu'il est
obligé conduite qu'on le force à mettre
à la disposition de ses concurrents sans
aucun investissement 25 % de sa capacité
de production sans marge
car c'est lui terme est déjà en soi un
est fort regrettable l'imposent il lui
imposer de vendre en dessous de son prix
de revient
n'aura qu'une conséquence c'est de faire
payer au client
en conséquence un prix plus élevé jeudi
deux choses je me suis élevé avec
véhémence
je les reconnais contre le pillage des
intérêts d'edf et de la nation française
je continuerai à le faire tant qu'on me
prêtera la parole je ne concevrais pas
que le prix de cession soit inférieur à
42 euros ou qu'on remette en cause ce
qui est le résultat d'une analyse qui a
été longuement élaboré et arrêtés par
les deux chambres du parlement français
je ne comprendrais pas
les temps j'ai appris la patience la ged
j'attends de décret car le prix est
prévue dans le décret la loi prévoit lé
la logique la loi de dit l'equilibre le
décret doit préciser le prix de 42 euros
sans le minimum en dessous duquel nous
serons en dessous du coût de revient et
je trouve je ne reprendrai pas les
termes peuvent y est déjà employé ils
seront les mêmes donc les temps et je
m'élève eric violence contre les
assertions de tel ou tel qui
souhaiteraient que cet effet d'aubaine
d'enrichissement sans cause et sans
investissement garnissez résultats avec
comme conséquence une hausse du prix de
l'énergie parce que si on veut maintenir
les équilibres économiques d'edf il
faudra augmenter les prix et donc doublé
l'effet d'aubaine pour ceux qui en
bénéficieraient je ne comprendrais pas
le rôle d'edf dans le marché des
capacités de l'effacement il est par
nature essentielle mais je ne vois pas
qui autres d'autre que des f peuvent
jouer ce rôle alors on peut en céder une
partie où un délégué une partie à des
gens qui seraient plus habiles ou plus
expérimentés ou des experts que je j'ai
l'esprit très ouvert
je cherche pas encore trouvé mais ce
n'est pas de l'autosatisfaction ni de la
suffisance simple réalisme quand la
france a construit un outil qui lui
permet de d2 voire l'électricité atouts
compétitifs d'europe 40% en dessous de
la moyenne européenne
hors france pourquoi faudrait-il
détruire ce que nos générations ont
construit je n'arrive pas à trouver de
réponse à cette question autre que de
respecter le travail le dévouement le
l'efficacité le savoir faire et la
volonté politiques qui ont conduit à
cette situation
l'allemagne grand pays que je respecte
infiniment je trouve que l'allemagne est
un pays industriel et qui a une vraie
politique industrielle
sauf dans un domaine c'est celui de
l'énergie et dans ce domaine là
l'allemagne a perdu pied a tourné le dos
pour des tas de raisons à la fois à
l'énergie thermique traditionnel en
refusant probablement à juste titre le
charbon mais il ne se livrant pas des
études et des analyses il ya des
constructions de licharre ball trap dans
le charbon propre la critique dans la
limite quand refusant le gaz pour des
raisons de dépendance vis-à-vis de l'est
refusent nucléaire produisons
théologique et ce livre ont délibérément
à la seule énergie aléatoire répartie et
hors de prix qui est l'énergie dites
renouvelables
sans doute avez-vous d'ailleurs
constater que la première des énergies
renouvelables c'est l'énergie
hydraulique mais que l'allemagne n'est
pas riche en montagne et donc
l'allemagne est aujourd'hui totalement
dépendante à la fois de ses importations
et en même temps de la défaillance de sa
politique énergétique et cherche par ce
qu'elle a compris ce qu'était la
compétitivité des territoires à imposer
aux autres les conséquences de son
manque de pertinence dans cette
stratégie
je serais plus explicite
si j'avais plus de temps mais dont des
réglementations orangemen poussé par les
allemands qui font que et 3 fois 20 des
440 et 5 x 50 etc et nous poussant à
subventionner à haute dose une énergie
dont nous n'avons pas besoin qui est
aléatoire et non compétitif de manière à
ce que la compétitivité que nous avons
acquise ne soit pas pérenne et d'où la
loi nome derrière alors il s'est produit
un événement c'est que la de nous étions
actionnaires minoritaires à 45 % aux
côtés des communes la demande d'énergie
badine vertonne d'arc y ait eu une
béquille et l'électricien pas de
versement lente puissant et disposant
d'une stratégie industrielle forte
abritant les grandes industries
automobiles siemens était dans le bade
wurtemberg est un pays riche un homme
riche non endetté et qui a faim dans le
président a pris
l'initiative très très récente et dans
le cadre d'une campagne électorale
difficile 2 entre guillemets pour
renationaliser relents disait son
électricien local c'est-à-dire un bébé
puisque les communes avaient déjà 45% et
qui est l'autorité de tutelle des
communes il a décidé de lancer une
proposition unilatérale de rachat dès 45
ans un couple d'étudiants faisant
clairement état de sa volonté de
recentrer sur le land l'ensemble des
ambitions de mbv donc de couper court à
tout les développements internationaux
en dehors du lente et de sa volonté de
se réapproprier l'outil nous aurions pu
ne pas accepter ça nous aurait conduit à
rester puisqu'on était en renégociation
de notre partenariat
le contrat initial de 2010 prévoyait une
revoyons rendu en 2000 par d'en prouver
une revoyure en 2011 et que le contrat
de partenariat et et à réécrire et donc
on risque est de se retrouver dans une
situation de minoritaires financiers et
privés de tout droit de gestion
industrielle ce qui n'est pas notre
vocation donc sans être vendeur puisque
je n'ai pas souhaité gender j'ai
accueilli la proposition nous avons
négocié les conditions de cette
proposition unilatérale et nous l'avons
acceptée dans des conditions de prix qui
permette de valoriser convenablement cet
outil sachant que le pays'' a également
frappé par la taxe sur nucléaire d'une
part et par les placements du prix du
gaz de l'autre prépare des lendemains
difficiles mais que le plan business
plan des trois quatre années qui
viennent et est particulièrement
douloureux on a cédé notre participation
à 20% au-dessus du cours de bourse
c'est un prix convenable
ça n'était pas une option stratégique
c'est simplement une opportunité au fond
de valoriser un actif dont le sort était
compromis par une volonté de ne pas nous
laisser la gestion industrielle et
opérationnels ce qui pourrait nous
effrayait les et une situation j'ai une
zone idéale donc nous avons encaissé 4
milliards 700 millions de cette
participation
ce qui valorise de manière satisfaisante
les investissements qui avaient été
réalisés et non pas spéculative et ça se
traduit par un désendettement que la
balle de 7 milliards du groupe edf on a
dit en arrivant que le groupe et edf
étaient surendettées il n'est pas
surendettée intrinsèquement mais les
investissements considérables qui sont à
consentir à la fois pour les extensions
durée de vie et la maintenance du parc
français dont je parlais tout à l'heure
les développements internationaux et
notamment britanniques et les ambitions
que nous avons forte de développer le
groupe sont que après 17 milliards de
cessions d'actifs britanniques réguler
sur les réseaux les 7 milliards de
cessions ou de désendettement à demain
et l'apport a été de 50% des rt au fonds
dédié qui les aident le groupe de 6
milliards
je vous amène aujourd'hui un
désendettement global de 23 milliards du
groupe en un an sans avoir amputé ni sa
force industrielle ni ses ambitions mais
on lui a redonné la flexibilité dont ils
avaient besoin pour sa stratégie aux
parents des mots alors est ce que pour
autant nous fermons la porte de
l'allemagne certainement pas l'allemagne
d'abbaye compliqué je voulais difficile
mais dans lesquels il existe des
opportunités que nous sommes en train
d'étudier
je vous en rendre est bien bien sûr
compte en temps réel ou en temps voulu
me n'en voudrait pas de ne pas élaborer
plus sur les opportunités potentielles
car il est rare qu'un industriel
souhaite exposer ses perspectives ou ses
opportunités avant même qu'elle ne se
produise
donc nous aurons le temps d'y revenir en
temps voulu
qu'est ce qu'on fera du désendettement
on donnera une encore une fois on va pas
me dire à la fois la société trop
endetté une fois quand la désendetter
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de
l'argent parce que si toi mais c'est
souvent le cas je vous rassure c'est
même en permanence le cam eh bien nous
ne les dépenseront pas n'importe comment
et donc nous allons mettre cette
flexibilité financière au profit de
notre croissance et au profit des
investissements industriels dans le
groupe a besoin et je vous promets que
cet argent sera investi avec le souci
est la pingrerie qui sied à n'importe
quel chef d'entreprise futile
d'entreprises nationales vous étonner
alors le développement international
areva alstom ne faut pas s'étonner de la
solidarité que j'exprime vis-à-vis de
l'industrie française
ou alors ça serait faire peu de cas de
patriotisme économique donc je pense que
c'est pas forcément un gros mot le
rapport roussely a dit des évidences
alors c'est évident sont évidemment
combattue par par la mode
il a dit il est naturel que celui qui
possède la meilleure expertise et le
plus grand retour d'expérience soit le
chef de file de la filière
alors je vous citerai une anecdote est
une expérience vécue
l'anecdote c'est premier voyage que je
fais en dehors du périphérique français
lors de ma prise de fonction connaissant
un peu la scie depuis des années me
paraissait naturel d'aller dans ce grand
pays me présente et se mettre dans mes
nouvelles fonctions haut responsable
chinois parce qu'ils sont très très
sensible la native du personnel et au
respect quand la rareté donc je suis
allé à pékin et j'ai rencontré notamment
le miz l'énergie est un personnage
puissant dans ce petit pays d'asie et
l'entretien était prévu pour 35 minutes
par les chinois sont très rigoureux sur
les calendriers il a duré une heure
quarante ans les temps de 3 minutes on
était assez facile à comprendre c'est
comment font les chinois vous êtes assis
sur le siège parallèle avec un data
d'aia les fleurs au milieu et chacun se
tourne un peu vers le micro et écoute
l'autre avec attention et donc après les
salamalecs d'usagé monsieur le président
je suis très honoré et très heureux de
vous recevoir mais ces mini suis très
honoré que le morceau via terra lui
sinon en substance m'a dit monsieur le
président peut-être avez-vous compris
que la chine avait évolué peut-être
avez-vous compris que la chine était
désormais un pays important pays qui a
les moyens financiers de ses ambitions
un pays qui a construit une croissance
économique significative et durable
un pays qui dispose d'élite et d'une
capacité de création de ces élites et
qui dispose d'une industrie dans
désormais les normes sont au niveau
occidentale d'une expertise d'un marché
intérieur et 6
kiko nucléaire je peux développer
l'ensemble de ses composantes et pour
finir en me disant monsieur le président
je vous remercie des 20 ans de
coopération que nous avons noué qui ont
donné naissance à l'industrie nucléaire
chinoise et la construction de ce qui
deviendra le port du parc nucléaire
mondial
peut-être avez-vous compris que
désormais nous n'aurons plus besoin de
vous le sac ça voulait dire et je lui ai
répondu monsieur le ministre j'ai un
immense respect pour votre grand pays
pour la maîtrise dont vous avez fait
preuve de votre développement pour les
formidable bond en avant les progrès la
croissance la richesse les évolutions et
je sais que vous avez à la fois l'
expertise la compétence l'industrie mais
assez chose en vous ne disposez pas la
seule c'est le retour d'expérience et ça
c'est l'actif essentiel fondamental
qu'il vous faudra 20 ans 30 ans par les
50 dont nous avons besoin nous mais
peut-être pas les vingt ans pour que
vous en disposez donc ce que vous
apporte edf s'est pas seulement son
expertise son savoir-faire ses
ingénieurs et ses compétences et aussi
ce formidable atout est il que constitue
le retour d'expérience et peut-être
avez-vous compris que nous serions un
des acteurs du paysage électro nucléaire
mondial en dehors des frontières
françaises nous avons déjà la fiabilité
de compte le parc nucléaire britannique
était héréditaire à l'italie la hollande
la pologne bien au-delà des frontières
ont au delà de l'europe et donc le
partenariat entre nos deux pays
tu es certainement partenariat qui fait
sens parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
partenaires possibles en anglais comme
l'entrée à la sortie de cet entretien
qui a duré une heure de plus que prévu
nous devons nous avons signé avec mme
achta et moi même une extension de notre
coopération
contrat étant de 50 ans la coopération
notre contrat de partenariat avec cgnpc
qui est l'acteur chinois avec lequel
nous avons un accord de coopération est
signé avec cnnc l'autre acteur ne
comptera de 50 ans également
c'est donc une formidable reconnaissance
que de se constituer des aides en
matière nucléaire dans le monde et y
compris la chine
voilà pourquoi edf a cette réputation
voilà ce que cherchent les opérateurs
nucléaires et notamment et en commençant
par les électriciens alors quand on me
dit l'expérience
j'essaie de l'anecdote à l'expérience
mais quand on est opérateur on peut pas
vendre d'équipement un autre opérateur
je suis attendu cette balivernes a
quelquefois quelques reprises mais très
mauvaise expérience de 40 ans passés
dans un modèle d'entreprise qui
s'appelait la générale des eaux et qui
est devenu veolia et dont nous avons
fait le premier rappeur mondial en
matière de traitement d'eau et le
premier intérêt mondial en matière de
traitement de déchets ça a été fait
uniquement en raison justement du fait
que nous apportions ce retour
d'expérience d'exploitation à des gens
qui en avaient besoin et qui s'appelait
des exploitants on ne serait jamais
devenu le premier constructeur mondial
d'usinés de traitement d'eau qu'elles
soient propres eaux usées premier le
premier constructeur mondial usine de
traitement des chaleurs communément
jamais quand ce que le moindre four nous
ne sommes pas vendeurs d'équipement du
tout si on n'avait pas vendu ses essais
ses usines ses outils à des opérateurs
concurrents
qu'il s'agisse de régie municipale ou
d'opérateurs privés bien entendu donc il
n'y a aucune contre indication
bien au contraire où que ce soit dans le
monde et je vous mets au défi de trouver
aucune contre référence au cul
alors vous avez parlé de l'afrique du
sud oui c'est vrai que les sud-africains
clause qui veulent développer le
nucléaire
on dit souvent eu des gens qui sont
exprimés pourquoi est ce que les années
elle refuserait d'où vient cette
pétition de principe alors nous verrons
ce que l'un d'eux fera mais je crois que
ceux qui construiront les centrales
nucléaires seront des électriciens et
qu'ils auront besoin du retour
d'expérience d'edf c'est mon credo
donc il n'y a aucune contre-indication
vite voilà ce que je pouvais répondre
merci une seule président dont il ya
toute une série de questions j'ai essayé
de regrouper en un peu l'eau que cinq
intervenants est à peu près 5 après
alors michel teston oui ce qui est bien
quand on est membre de cette commission
c'est qu'à quelques jours d'intervalle
on peut avoir deux visions du nucléaire
français et qu'on peut avoir aussi deux
visions des rôles respectifs d'edf et
d'areva
je fais référence bien sûr à ce que nous
a dit il ya quelques jours madame
lauvergeon et ça ne correspond bien
évidemment pas tout à fait je n'ai pas
tout à fait à ce que nous avait dit
aujourd'hui au delà de de ce constat la
vraie question est la suivante est ce
que la france peut peut se permettre de
rester sur deux visions différentes du
nucléaire dans un secteur qui est
pourtant aussi stratégique
ça c'est ma première question est par
ailleurs jean poserait une autre sur le
président j'ai bien noté les
circonstances dans lesquelles vous avez
été amené à cédé les 45% que vous
déteniez dans le capital électricien
allemand vw pour faire droit à la
demande du land de bade wurtemberg qui à
l'évidence souhaitait pouvoir maîtriser
la politique l'électricité sur son
territoire ceci étant même si le marché
allemand est un marché difficile même si
à l'avenir il sera probablement d'élite
pouvoir s'y développer est-ce que vous
ne considérez pas que c'est malgré tout
un marché sur lequel il faut être
présent
alors vous nous avez dit que nous ne
livrerons pas aujourd'hui vos réflexions
sur ce qui pourrait être fait pour vous
irez implanter rapidement mais en tout
cas il me semble que vous ne pouvez pas
être je dirais en dehors du marché
allemand de l'électricité puisque c'est
un marché très important
merci à sa collègue roland courteau
oui merci monsieur le président sur
l'international d'avoir une simple
question
l'acquisition de british energy par edf
au royaume uni at elle été une bonne
affaire contenu et de son prix est de
l'état de cette société sur la loi nome
que nous avons combattu
faut-il rappeler je vois que nous avons
tous dit lors de l'examen du projet de
loi en séance je le redis encore une
fois on a l'impression de marcher sur la
tête mais je n'ajouterai rien de plus
sur le fond sur le prix de l'arenh
ladislas poniatowski a soulevé le
problème je n'y reviens pas mais il
semble que ça se précise si mes
informations sont bonnes je vois que le
ministre l'industrie a nommé une a
confié une mission à paul champsaur pour
déterminer le prix de la non à suivre
donc dans mes informations ne sont pas
bonnes questions sur rte
plus encore récemment la presse a
annoncé que vous aviez l'intention
d'affecter 50% de rtl aux actifs dédiés
permettant de faire face ainsi aux coûts
futurs de démantèlement des centrales
nucléaires et de stockage des déchets
radioactifs à la question peut-on avoir
plus de précisions sur cette opération
qui alors on vient de me le dire à
l'instant nous semble déjà être bouclée
si j'en crois une dépêche de l'agencé
r quelle conséquence monsieur le
président pour rte
et puis surtout quelles garanties
attendent qu'une telle affectation ne
remettra pas en cause le caractère
intégré du groupe avec une filiale à
capitaux totalement public et si
l'opération ne porte que sur une partie
des actifs de rte 50% indique-t-on
quelles sont les garanties pour l'autre
moitié de ses actifs et pour la
préservation de l'intégrité de cette
filiale qui attire bien des convoitises
faut-il le dire et le répéter enfin que
se passera-t-il au moment du dénouement
de l'opération
merci au cirque avec françois fortassin
président monsieur le président d'edf
d'abord je dois dire que j'ai beaucoup
de satisfaction à voir que vous revenez
demain nous à l'époque je m'étais
quelque peu ému que vous soyez en même
temps précisant qu'en dix ans la
présidence d'edf et de veolia j'avais
été légèrement brocardé par un certain
nombre de mes collègues mais je
m'aperçois que ma mon étonnement ou mon
émotion n'était pas au fond tellement
étonnant puisque les choses sont de ce
côté-là rentré dans l'ordre mais ça
n'est pas de ce problème que je veux
parler simplement ma question sera très
brève il se trouve que la f1 ne sert ccr
pardon qui regroupe les syndicats
départementaux d'électricité qui est
présidée par notre excellent collègue
xavier pintât est actuellement dans une
situation de vive émotion par rapport à
certaines déclarations que vous auriez
fait ou intentions alors cela s'est
produit la semaine dernière je n'étais
pas cette réunion je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez éventuellement votre pensé qu'
il y a eu une émotion extrêmement vives
de ce côté-là et une assez grande
inquiétude
c'est du moins ce qui ressortit
puisqu'on a demandé aux présidents de
ces syndicats départementaux
d'électricité d'écrire de la façon la
plus immédiate que ce qu'ils soient à
madame lagarde est monsieur baroin
merci mon cher collègue
il fait par des émotions robert navarro
et deux simples interrogations et
conviction que j'ai personnellement
monsieur président proview est un conte
plein de ce qu'a dit mon ami michel
teston il est évident que nous avons
deux splendides et outils en france qui
sont arrivés à edf de splendides et
outils qui de mon point de vue est de
paralyser fonctionne très mal à
l'extérieur de l'hexagone
il fonctionne très mal pourquoi parce
qu'il sort en permanence en concurrence
pas forcément au niveau des outils mais
au niveau des responsables et moi je
suis de ceux qui pensent que vous êtes
le plus à même d'être celui qui sera le
responsable de l'ensemble des outils
parce que c'est l'un des rares domaines
où on peut aller travailler dans la
mondialisation encore faire des
bénéfices et gagner de l'argent
notre pays n'a pas les moyens de se
payer le luxe de perdre là les domaines
où il peut gagner de l'argent dans
perdre dont je crois qu'au mans donné il
faudra qu'on clarifie nous est à france
et le fait d'avoir deux entreprises
performances et qui ne rapporte pas ce
qu'elle devrait apporter au pays parce
que les gouvernants ce ne sont pas de
mon point de vue les plus efficaces
possibles dans l'amélioration de cette
gouvernance cela est ce qu elle être
vous prêt à accompagner ce que je viens
de dire
première question deuxièmement vous avez
parlé d' outils financiers non adaptés
dont on a besoin
est-ce que vous pouvez pousser plus loin
votre idée est 6ème éclairez moi j'ai ma
petite idée mais modestement j'attendrai
la voix votre vision qui est beaucoup
plus performant que moi pour savoir si
quels sont les outils qu'on peut mettre
en place pour aller beaucoup plus loin
dans la rue
novation de toutes nos centrales et dans
la réalisation de certains projets à
l'international
merci chers collègues dernier pour la
première partie marc daunis ou une
question qui tourne autour de deux
éléments le premièrement développement
de la filière nucléaire française a été
marqué historiquement par des choix
technologiques
j'ai gardé l'origine entre le graphite
gaz l'eau pressurisée
comment vous voyez à l'heure où les
délais s'allongent indéfiniment les
coûts explosent par rapport le p r
des choses première éléments sur quels
choix technologiques vous pensez qu'il
convient que nous parions et quel type
de diversification éventuellement dans
l'offre est toujours dans la mini idée
mais lié aussi à la question des
investissements dans votre peau venez
dire je veux faire un résumé qui sera
vraisemblablement caricatural mais
grosso modo la rénovation du parc
national des capacités de production
nationales parc nucléaire est quasiment
supérieur
au programme internationaux je
caricature je veux un peu vite mais en
l'occurrence c'était un peu l'idée que
vous sembliez induire temps c'est dans
ce contexte qu'elle serait quels sont
vos choix et doit entendre alliance
modulable terme que je crois vous avez
employé dans la présentation
une sorte de partenariat la carte qui
vous positionnerait dans votre coeur de
métier ce que devait appeler perriand
s'accumuler avec des choix
technologiques qui serait adaptée à des
situations dit en d'autres termes ici
avec un constructeur chinois haier
éventuellement dans un tour de table aux
côtés des coréens plus que dans une
solution européenne ou française
mais en jouant pleinement votre carte
j'allais dire personnel ce qui vit un
dans la continuité des questions
précédentes et enfin et je m'arrêterai
là
beaucoup de questions ont été évoquées
par ladislas poniatowski et qui faisait
partie des interrogations que nous
pouvons avoir
et sur lesquels vous remercier d'avoir
apporté quelques éclairages
merci à charles collecte chez le
président je vous propose de répondre 5
revenant devant monsieur testons beau
devions différentes c'est possible forme
je vous dis vrai mienne donc je ne suis
pas capable
je n'entrerai pas dans la moindre
polémique je conçois qu'il peut y avoir
des divergences de vues parfois damienne
les forget s'est forgée c'est une
conviction je vous livre ma vision de
relais des fn est architecte ensemblier
il y a à côté de nous des acteurs
industriels auxquels nous ferons une
place la plus importante possible pour
ne pas dire prépondérante puisque ça va
dépendre des pays des développements à
téhéran et je parlais d'alstom j'ai
parlé d'un certain de société réveil à
sa place on dans le domaine des
chaudières en particulier dans le
domaine de l'alimentation armand sur le
combustible
pour ne pas dire de l'aval du cycle où
ils ont un monopole dans leur traitement
donc nous sommes le premier client
d'areva et de très très loin franchement
on n'a pas de reproches à formuler
df à cet égard donc j'ai dit simplement
que il faut encore l'architecte
ensemblier ekoué le concepteur
constructeur comme le disent les anglo
saxons vous avez le design gilt et puis
le design build operate c'est-à-dire
construction enfin
conception-construction participation à
la gestion des opérations et puis vous
avez ceux qui sont des les
équipementiers ou les génies civilistes
enfin évidemment qu'on ne va pas faire
ou non mamba vocation à être industriels
fabricants d'équipements rentrant dans
la construction des centrales
on a besoin d'une filière industrielle
cohérente compétentes compétitive et
qu'ils soient organisées dans laquelle
la france sera privilégiée par nous
autant que faire se peut mais ne nous
leurrons pas l'essentiel du
développement du nucléaire
une nouveau nucléaire se fera hors de
france bien entendu c'est pas en france
que la seule et en dehors de france il
faudrait faire une place à des
industriels à rolls royce d'un côté
finmeccanica de l'autre russe ou chinois
en fonction des zones d'influencé en
fonction de la spécificité d'efficacité
de leurs outils
voilà ce que je pense au fond est ce
tout cela n'est pas doctrinaire c'est
simplement à dossier à une réalité à du
simple bon sens et à une expérience
vécue et par conséquent je dis
simplement ce qui est la réalité
quand vous faites construire une maison
vous avez un architecte et puis vous
avez des gens qui font le génie civil
des gens qui font la plomberie des gens
qui font des choses très importantes le
système électrique qui sont des
spécialistes et industriels du métier et
c'est pas l'architecte qui va tout faire
mais il est concepteur et dans ce métier
très particulier le concepteur
opérateurs qui a
encore une fois qui risquent de son
retour d'expérience un rôle très
particulier à jouer très important d'où
le fait que ces espaces de françois
roussely en tant qu'homme et la mission
qu'il a été chargé d'animer qui était
constitué de personnalités très
différentes a reconnu à l'évidence le
rôle de chef de file à celui qui en
l'occurrence en europe et pas uniquement
en france méritent ce cette terminologie
de concepteurs architectes ensembliers
voilà c'est tout il n'y a pas de
polémique dans ce que je dis c'est une
simple considération des de l'histoire
et des compétences existantes
je signale d'ailleurs au passage ce qui
n'est pas assez reconnu ou 10 par nos
compatriotes et d'ailleurs par serre par
leurs représentants est bourré de
modestie et de respect qu'ils méritent
tous les opérateurs électriques
européens font construire leurs
équipements leurs centrales par les
architectes ensembliers spécialisées
c'est-à-dire des bureaux d'ingénierie ou
et par des industriels
aucun n'a les capacités
de l'ingénierie capable de créer les
outils sauf edf
c'est lié à l'histoire c'est lié au rôle
auquel edf a dû accéder à la demande des
pouvoirs publics de concevoir de
construire et d'opérer un parc nucléaire
français eh bien nous pourrions nous
contenter de faire comme tout le monde
est au fond de supprimer l'ingénierie et
de dire après tout on sera opérateur et
on fera appel à des ingénieristes
indépendant d'hiver ce que fait bertel
aux états unis pour tous les opérateurs
et dans bien d'autres pays du monde
aucun européen ne sait le faire en
dehors tenez aucun ne revient à l'ouest
de l'elbe à l'est cette chose donc ayant
conscience de cela
est-ce qu'on veut ou pas utiliser cette
carte qui est l'atout de la france dans
la compétition duclair mondiale à la
question posée
il suffit de répondre donc pas de
polémique
un constat une conviction et si possible
une action s'élève à 40% des actions de
votre bébé je vous ai dit dans ces
circonstances est pourquoi et peut-on
être absent du marché allemand
on peut en être absent c'est pas une
absolue nécessité pour autant il y a des
opportunités qui s'offrent ou qui
peuvent souffrir et nous ne serons pas
absent de ces opportunités monsieur
courteau me poser la question son
acquisition de british energy est ce que
c'est une bonne affaire on en reparlera
dans cinq derniers c'est embêtant
aujourd'hui les conditions enfin la
particularité de la grande bretagne
quand même ces cas là une vraie
politique énergétique
un des rares pays européens à avoir une
vraie politique énergétique j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec l'ancien
premier ministre gordon brown de sa
politique énergétique et de sa décision
de relancer le nucléaire
il a été ensuite battu aux élections par
une coalition entre les libéraux et
les conservateurs et j'ai eu l'occasion
de m'entretenir avec vous nouveau
premier ministre de sa vision du monde
et il se trouve qu'elle correspond
parfaitement à celle de son prédécesseur
et que non seulement il l'a annoncé non
seulement elle a été dans son programme
électoral mais qu'en plus de la mer 9
et force est de constater que ces
repaires de bruit la semaine dernière
non il ya dix jours au parlement
britannique
la loi la loi sur l'énergie a été votée
avec en particulier le programme
nucléaire et qu'elle a recueilli 90 7 %
de votes favorables de la part des
députés quelle que soit leur tendance
sujet qui n'a jamais été notés nulle
part dans la presse française ou en fait
état des états d'âme des verrats n'en ai
jamais des gens qui ont une vraie
politique jamais et je trouve surprenant
qu aucun journal aucune revue personne
ne les mentionner or quand les gens sont
vertueux ont une vraie politique on n'en
parle pas on ne parle que de ce qui ne
marche pas trouve ça assez désolant je
reviens la question précédente séparés
quand ça marche quand ça marche il faut
il faut casser donc dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va continuer à faire quelque chose
qui marche plutôt que d'essayer de les
détruire et quelque chose qui ne marche
pas et bien c'est pareil en matière
politique
c'est assez surprenant cette espèce de
volonté absolue de construire le
désastre mais c'est comme ça donc la
grande bretagne a une politique
il se trouve que nous avons pris le pari
au fonds britannique et que ce pari
semble être en bonne voie puisque les
textes réglementaires sont en cours 1 et
que le sujet et adossés notamment un
prix minimum du carbone ce qui incarne
carbone flore qui doit être voté au
printemps de l'année 2011 mais donc
c'est le programme britannique est en
train de se construire pierre à pierre
et nous ferons un grand acteur
britannique et la grande-bretagne quand
même une référence dans d'autres pays du
monde que simplement les îles
britanniques puisque comme vous le savez
le commonwealth n'est pas vraiment il y
à quelques pays qui adopteront
probablement une politique comparable
celle de la grande bretagne et donc il
sera pas inutile qu'on soit par
les acteurs principaux de la grande
bretagne dans ce double mais en ce qui
concerne l'équation purement financière
de savoir si on a fait un bon
investissement encore une fois rien ne
me permet de le critiquer c'est à l'aune
de l'histoire convoi s'est investi temps
et bon temps dans les retours pour
l'instant on n'est pas déçu les outils
financiers dont on a besoin bon bah ça
veut dire des mots des systèmes de
financement les états unis la chine ont
construit des types des financements
d'état pour développer des
infrastructures dans des pays tiers et
et pour aider à l'exportation de leurs
de leur industrie c'est vrai que la
france a à cet égard un peu de retard
par rapport à ces pays là est peut-être
pas les mêmes ressources mais encore
faut-il en est conscient et essayer en
tout état de cause de faire au mieux
face à sète à cette problématique pour
autant nous ne sommes encore une fois
nous nous n'avons pas vocation à être
propriétaire de centrales nucléaires
partout dans le monde
c'est pas le sujet nous sommes
concepteurs opérateurs maître d'ouvragé
délégué on peut être architecte
ensemblier tirer la filière industrielle
pour le compte d'opérateurs sans avoir
besoin des investisseurs par conséquent
il faut que de plus en plus dans dans l'
architecture même des contrats nous
apprenions à baisser l'intensité
capitalistique
le but n'est pas d'être propriétaire
d'un outil de production partout dans le
monde
mais en fin de temps en temps il est
quand même bon de pouvoir y participer
e
monsieur d'aunis me poser la question
des choix technologiques eau pressurisée
à titre a bien entendu que les choix
technologiques sont essentiels mais ils
sont à évolution lente c'est à dire
qu'au fond il faut qu' il faut que nos
équipes de r&d gravats fortement sur les
futures technologies sur la quatrième
génération en particulier et donc il n'y
aura pas mais ça
le nucléaire est une activité à cycle
long bien entendu donc il n'y aura pas
de sauts technologiques immédiat il faut
préparer la quatrième génération dès
aujourd'hui de manière à ce que nous
techniciens le spécialiste soit capable
de d'offrir dans l'avenir les meilleurs
produits et nous y contribuons beaucoup
nous sommes l'électricien au monde qui a
la plus grande force
les recherches et développement plus
gros budget le plus grand nombre de
chercheurs
opérationnel au loupé herbe ont letr est
un premier de sa génération donc il faut
l'industrialiser je reconnais que comme
dans tout lot il faut passer par des
phases de mise au point des cerises des
réalisations n'est ce pas là donc il ne
faut pas critiquer ni ni attaquer les
débuts ont été un peu difficile parce
qu'il n'y avait pas d'expérience acquise
donc c'est une nouvelle étape c'est un
nouveau modèle il faut qu'on étende
industrialisés c'est en cours ballet de
rénovation du parc nucléaire d
investissement c'est vrai que les
investissements réalisés sur le parc
nucléaire français sont considérables
alors ils sont pas tout à fait
comparable aux investissements à
l'international puisque à
l'international on va accompagner les
investissements on les fera pas tous on
va pas être propriétaire ce que je vous
dit à l'instant donc c'est des choses
qui sont pas tout à fait comparable
et deuxièmement il est naturel que le
prix les prix français rémunère les
investissements nécessaires à l'ensemble
des outils de production de distribution
et de transport nécessaires à la gestion
du service public en france donc nous
sommes pour l'instant déséquilibre de
cash flow et c'est à dire qu'on a
investi plus que le catch d'entreprise
ici naturel puisqu'on est arrivé à la
phase où il faut investir massivement
dans la modernisation et l'extension de
la durée de vie des centrales
bon encore une fois trente ans durée de
vie elles sont pratiquement à mortier
aux trois quarts elle rêvait 40,1 durée
de vie prévisible
on va essayer de passer à 60 ans donc il
faut faire des investissements
considérables je vous avais dit lors des
réunions sur la loi nome de l'ordre de
35 milliards d'investissements destinés
à l'extension de la durée vie non par
emplacement en renouvellement eh bien
ces investissements sont à programmer
dans les cinq qui a dix ans qui viennent
on en a déjà les premières traces dans
le plan moyen terme 2010 2013
le ci ajoute les 4,5 milliards
d'investissements de maintenance
courante du parc et ça représente des
montants très significatifs
d'investissement c'est ce à quoi je
faisais du leader mais rien d'inquiétant
si simplement
via un outil industriel lourd et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me bats donc
pour que des prix de cession soit en
tiennent compte
parler de partenariat la carte n'est pas
le sujet si nous voulons garder une
filière nucléaire française edf sera
déterminant
edf a toujours fait la part belle aux
entreprises françaises des industries
françaises qui l'ont accompagné dans le
développement de son programme en france
en grande bretagne aujourd'hui puisqu'on
fait des epn
mais encore une fois il faut également
que cette organisation de la filière
sera suffisamment efficace suffisamment
soudé et confiante pour accepter son
élargissement des industriels
internationaux non sans lesquels nous ne
serons pas en situation de pouvoir
gagner les appels d'offres mondiaux ou
ne ferai pas de nucléaire en italie sans
des grands industriels italiens et donc
il faut trouver à l'intérieur de cette
filière une ouverture possible à des
partenariats effectivement qu'ils soient
britanniques dans certains moments un
certain moment italiens russes chinois
ou autres sans lesquels voient droff ne
sera pas compétitive au trac
acceptabilité ne sera pas possible et
donc c'est ça que je voulais dire c'est
tout grande coopération entre les
entreprises françaises pour justement
permettre ce pas
merci monsieur le président vous êtes
encore kata intervenir juments de 5 ans
les questions donc j'ai donné la parole
à jacques blanc très gros merci à
monsieur le président et maureen d'avoir
évité d'autres membres de la commission
ce qui nous permet d'entendre avec
beaucoup d'intérêt monsieur proglio sur
un sujet qui
nous paraît essentiel et sur lesquels
les politiques peuvent avoir quelques
fierté parce que quand même les choix
politiques français par rapport au
nucléaire
quel que soit d'ailleurs les
sensibilités politiques ont permis de
faire cet outil merveilleux que vous
nous avez présenté tout à l'heure alors
je voudrais cerner mon deux
interrogations pour être rapide c'est
sur le problème du transport et
distribution
il ya un partenariat très fort entre les
collectivités territoriales et erdf
puisque nous avons en france 2
particularité d'avoir les collectivités
propriétaires le réseau erdf
concessionnaires et nous paraît
important que ce soit à conforter la
confiance dans ce partenariat notre
collègue forte à 5 évoqué tout à l'heure
un peu le problème
nous souhaitons qui est donc que
renforcement de ses liens et que nous
nous mobilisions par rapport au problème
de la couverture du territoire et
l'émotion qui a été soulevée c'était à
l'occasion la réunion sur le fasse et où
il nous paraît tout à fait important que
ce qui est un fonds de mutualisation qui
a permis qu à même d'assurer couverture
territoriale en france ne soit pas
amputée et que ce soit de négociation
partagé entre notre fédération nationale
dans notre ami pintât et erdf que l'on
puisse obtenir le maintien du niveau du
passé et des modalités qui permettent
aux collectivités territoriales de jouer
leur rôle en pleine confiance avec erdf
donc c'est un point tout à fait concret
et précis
le deuxième point c'est savoir où en
sont les grands projet porté d'ailleurs
par rte dans le domaine du la boucle
méditerranéenne l'euro
méditerranée pour nous est en
perspective tout à fait forte
intéressante et dans les grands projets
de l'euroméditerranée figure cette
boucle méditerranéenne dans laquelle je
crois rte joue un rôle majeur et qui
peut demain avoir à la fois des
retombées des changes énergétique mais
peut-être aussi des bassins des
problèmes politiques des capacités
d'apporter sur l'ensemble de la
méditerranée des chances supplémentaires
et j'aimerais savoir ce que vous même en
pensée et quelles sont les perspectives
par rapport à l'action de rtl à ce
niveau merci mon cher collègue martial
bourquin
mais trois questions rapides ce
président-là l'énergie en france
ça fait partie de l'attractivité
concernant le sol français par rapport
aux investissements étrangers en général
par rapport à l'investissement
et si on veut rebâtir une industrie
forte il faut garder cette énergie moins
chère que les autres pays européens ce
absolument indispensable et je pense
qu'avec la loi nome il y à des possibles
dérives et lorsqu'on apprend ici là les
augmentations on peut comment être
craintifs quant à l'avenir et ces
augmentations
je dis ça par rapport aux
électro-intensifs que nous avons visités
dans le cadre de la mission industrie
qui sont très inquiets sur les suites de
la loi nome il est clair que c'est
électro-intensifs ne resteront pas chez
nous irons soit au canada dans le
meilleur des cas mais au pire en chine
où il y aura d'exister faite par le
charbon
si on augmente le prix de l'électricité
de façon qu'ils ne soient pas
raisonnable alors
cette question d'énergie moins cher avec
une question capitale
ça fait partie de l'attractivité du sol
français la deuxième chose sur le
président j'avais parlé d'une stratégie
internationales pertinentes
elle est importante en aucun cas il doit
s'apparenter à des aventures
internationales parce qu'on sait très
bien que dans ces cas là ce sont les
contribuables qui est surtout les
usagers qui font les frais de ces
aventures internationales faut jamais
oublier que si on a une énergie moins
chère c'est parce que les usagers ont
déjà payé les centrales et cette énergie
pas cher elles étaient payées en grande
partie par les français troisième point
et ça je voudrais bien avoir votre avis
là-dessus monsieur le président
concernant les relations d'edf avec la
filière photovoltaïque filière solaire
française
je suis impressionné parfois d'aller à
des inaugurations pas loin de chez moi
par exemple où je suis maire un parking
complètement recouvert de photovoltaïque
avec une production importante mais
réalisés avec des capteurs chinois de
première génération qui ont une une
comment un une empreinte carbone
extrêmement élevé quand est ce qu edf
travaillera avec la filière française du
solaire et du photovoltaïque
je dis cela parce qu'il ya plusieurs
entreprises chez nous qui ont investi
très fort dans cette filière
photovoltaïque
elles ont besoin d'un contrat de filière
avec le grand donneur d'ordre qui est
qui et edf
alors bien sûr on sait très bien que ça
passe par des appels doivent bien sûr
mais dans ses appels d'offres pourquoi
ne mettons pas plus en exergue le bilan
carbone de ces capteurs solaires et on
sait très bien que la filière française
est en train de travailler sur les 3e et
janet et 4e génération de capteurs
photovoltaïques
quel est votre avis là-dessus on
aimerait que
edf donne un coup de pouce à la filière
solaire française merci chers collègues
alain fouché jeu le président quelques
mots seulement et encore c'est une
question j'ai très bref vous savez
monsieur mais simplement là non ça
commence bien
la loi nome je n'ai pas voté pour ma
part bien qu'étant de la majorité ont
voté contre
j'estimais que du mauvais texte on se
réfugie d'être toujours derrière
l'europe pour tout changer on va voir
demain en commission des affaires
économiques
un texte sur l'urbanisme commercial d'
contre le gouvernement et contre ses le
texte à quoi y est et on nous dit que à
cause de l'europe était en fait
l'allemagne vient de faire exactement la
même chose mais c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne
bon simplement ma question elle concerne
les énergies renouvelables on vient
moratoire qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement
je voudrais avoir je pense pas que les
retraités plus sûr et même de peu en
retard
votre vision sur la politique de
financement des énergies renouvelables
dans la durée voilà la seule question
qui cote
merci dans chaque collègue michel houel
et après une petite question
complémentaire
oui monsieur le président mon la
question sera très très court et très
brève
on sait que la consommation électrique
dans le monde va doubler d'ici 2050
donc lhi un bel avenir pour nous pour
toutes les entreprises françaises qui
sont dans le nucléaire et les français
sont très fiers très très fier du
nucléaire de leur nucléaire de toutes
les avancées qui ont été faites dans les
différentes sociétés qui travaillent
pour le nucléaire
or or il s'avère que l'échec d'abou
dhabi a été en a marqué profondément
certains français et moi même ce n'est
en fait pas parce que j'étais tellement
persuadé qu'on allait gagner le marché
pour moi il n'y avait pas de suspense
or on l'a perdu et je ne pense pas
personnellement que ce soit à cause de
la paix m mais que ce soit tout
simplement à cause d'une mauvaise
entente entre les différents acteurs qui
avait soumissionné pour abou dhabi
alors monsieur le président ma question
c'est celle ci
est ce que vous croyez pas qu'il est
temps de faire un pôle international
avec areva
avec bien sûr vous et puis d'autres
preneurs à l'ange allons jusqu'à total
jusqu'à suez environnement jusqu'à le
stum essayé peut-être pas si louable
essayé tout au moins de faire un grand
pôle international qui puisse intervenir
et qu'ils puissent être un interlocuteur
d'envergure pour pouvoir gagner les
marchés à venir
merci michel roland courteau pour
décision sur une question oui oui une
précision je vous ai posé une question
sur le président et je vois que vous
avez omis de répondre je vous disais que
la presse annonçait que vous aviez
l'intention d'affecter 50% de rte aux
actifs dédiés permettant de de faire
face aux coûts futurs de démantèlement
des centrales nucléaires et le stockage
des déchets radioactifs alors on me dit
on me dit que l'opération était bouclé
aujourd'hui
alors est ce que c'est vrai c'est une
dépêche qui viennent d'arriver là
l'instant cela signifie t'il que l'on
fait sortir la dette de rte de celle
d'edf
je me pose des questions alors peut-on
avoir plus de précisions sur cette
opération
quelles conséquences pour rte quelles
garanties at on une telle affectation ne
remettra pas en cause le caractère
intégré du groupe avec une filiale à
capitaux publics
merci monsieur le président vous
permettrait de vous poser une question
puisque quand vous êtes venu au mois de
juin dernier
vous êtes fixé comme objectif de porter
le taux de disponibilité des centrales
nucléaires à 85% cinq ans je lis un peu
la presse est ce que vous pourriez nous
donner quelques précisions pour savoir
où vous en êtes aujourd'hui jeu
je vais essayer de pas évident de ne pas
oublier des questions qui me sont posées
j'ai oublié et gaziers mission certes
cela je voudrais pas qu'il ait le
sentiment que je n'y réponds pas ni à
son attaque sur l'environnement ni où le
sujet du faso sur veolia environnement
rien n'est rentré dans l'ordre parce que
rien n'a jamais été dans le désordre g à
la demande du président de la république
accepté une mission jeunes était
candidat à rien et par conséquent il je
devais et je l'avais dit devant la
commission rené assumer une transition
très difficile de quitter une entreprise
qu'on a dirigé la modestement et
contribué à créer et du jour au
lendemain
choisir un successeur parmi les autres
et j'ai quitté le navire semble plus à
se préoccuper de son avenir alors qu'il
concerne trois cent mille personnes
simplement j'ai un autre sens de mon
devoir est de ma responsabilité
pardonnez moi et donc souhaité assumer
cette transition
honteux je dirais de président d'un
exécutif
je ne pense pas que pendant l'année qui
s'est écoulée
il m'était jamais reprocher à edf de ne
pas consacrer mon énergie mon temps et
mes efforts à cette entreprise est pas
entendu la moindre critique à cet égard
ce qui ne m'a pas empêché d'être le
président non exécutif de veolia pendant
le même temps en ayant une fois de temps
en temps une réunion avec les dirigeants
des entreprises pour les guider dans les
décisions essentielles ou stratégiques à
prendre
j'ai transmis dimanche soir ma
présidence au successeur que j'avais
désigné comme directeur général dans une
transition naturelle et donc je récuse
totalement le terme de désordre ou le
thème de baroque totalement et je
m'opposerai avec un dernière énergie à
toute allusion qui serait simplement de
la mauvaise foi
vous avez parlé du face et je suis navré
je n'étais pas non plus à cette réunion
cette décision n'a pas été la mienne
c'est celle de l'administration
française
donc j'assume bien des choses dans la
vie mais il n'a pas été pour l'instant
encore confié de rôle de responsable de
l'administration dans la franchement
erdf est un opérateur responsable et
digne de confiance
mais ne fait que respecter des règles
qui lui sont imposées donc si les règles
concernant le fasse échange ça n'est pas
la responsabilité de garder f kin et
coopérateurs c'est l'administration
française qui après une orientation que
je n'ai pas l'audace de critiquer ni
même de conforter dit simplement c'est
une orientation de l'administration dont
on peut discuter mais ce n'est pas de
mon ressort
je ne vais pas inspiré on me prête
beaucoup de choses mais je n'ai pas
inspiré
j'en assume la responsabilité hausse en
ce moment j'espère mora lutte sur le
sujet de rte là aussi pardonnez moi de
ne pas avoir répondu à la question j'ai
oublié de faire perte est alors le
conseil qui s'est réuni ce matin le
conseil d'edf s'est réuni ce matin pour
effectivement accepté l'opération dire
qu'elle est réalisée et donc 50% des rdt
et e
va être apportée au fonds dédiés alors
qu'est ce que le fonds dédié edf
constitue dans la perspective de du
démantèlement de ses centrales
nucléaires
un fonds qui est doté d'à peu près de 2
milliards 3 milliards par an en cash
pour kimi dans une tirelire destiné à
financer les travaux démantèlement qui
interviendront à terme alors le terme
risque d'être prolongé puisque si nous
prolongeons de 20 ans la durée de vie
nous ne toucherons à la cagnotte que
dans quarante ans
tendez si je puis me permettre
donc moi j'ai deux 2 obsession dans la
vie c'est la première c'est de ne pas
mettre dans une cagnotte taux toujours
en perte de contrôle et deuxièmement de
me dire qu'après tout comme la règle
même pose de ne pas être opérateurs de
rte puisque comme vous le savez rte
nous n'avons plus le droit je n'ai plus
le droit ni de désigner les organes de
direction j'ai eu des propositions mais
pas de décision
je n'ai aucun droit sur les
investissements évidemment aucun sur les
tarifs je suis un actionnaire à 100% on
peut dormant mais d'une société réguler
dont je suis propriétaire non opérateur
et je me disais qu'au fond le fait
d'apporter une partie de ces capitaux
qui ont un rendement garanti à un fonds
qui a pour vocation de prévoir le
démantèlement des centrales sans qu'on y
touche pendant 40 ans n'était peut-être
pas aussi stupide qu'il y paraît et pas
plus idiots qui met du cash que je vais
emprunter sur le marché
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité mettre 50 % du capital de rte
dans le fonds dédié
sachant que parallèlement je me suis
engagé contractuellement ne jamais
vendre ses titres et si je si par
extraordinaire
c'est qu'ils devaient être vendus je
m'oblige à les racheter à remplacer par
du cash
donc c'est très clair rtl continue à
être filiale à 100% sous contrôle d'edf
une partie en direct une partie autre
ère du fonds de démantèlement
c'est la décision qui a été prise et qui
est question de bon sens
donc il n'y a rien changé sur la
propriété d'rtl messieurs foucher m'a
posé je regardais s'il n'avait pas
oublié de question qu à la main sur les
énergies renouvelables
vaste sujet la première des sujets le
sujet est plus complexe qu'il n'y paraît
parce que d'abord la première des
énergies renouvelables hydraulique
on aurait tort d'oublier edf a construit
sa réputation d'abord sur ses
compétences hydroélectrique et je pense
qu'il est important de rappeler et de
leur dire systématiquement la première
des énergies renouvelables en france 15%
de la production et d'une pression
hydraulique
je voudrais pas qu'on oublie ensuite il
ya les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
l'éolien onshore et offshore le
photovoltaïque et toutes autres formes
d'énergies renouvelables dans lesquels
on trouve la biomasse dans lesquels on
trouve le waste to energy et ses
bâtiments
c'est à dire des énergies réparties et
aléatoire les deux c'est à dire non non
centralisés et dont les rendements sont
à l'aise dans l'est la production est
aléatoire parce que
en fonction du vent du soleil la
capacité de production n'est pas garanti
c'est ça qui fait parce que laïcs et des
énergies dites renouvelables de nouvelle
génération
donc la position d'edf c'est aller
pragmatique
1 nous en faut nous en faisons et nous
devons maîtriser des technologies et
avoir une part d'énergies renouvelables
dans notre potentiel énergétique en tout
cas dans le monde sûrement en france un
peu aussi en même temps le réalisme
économique ne doit pas occulter lui être
occultée donc clairement les énergies
renouvelables coûts infiniment plus cher
beaucoup plus cher que l'énergie
électro-nucléaire ou d'énergie
hydraulique entre deux à trois fois pour
les lumières pour l'éolien une fois et
demie à trois fois en fonction du fait
qu'il s'agit d'un tube d'accord entre 10
et 20 fois en ce qui concerne le
photovoltaïque et donc le développement
de ces d'ingénieurs dites renouvelables
creuser des déficits considérables à la
charge en principe de l'état en fait
d'edf puisque ses couverts par la cspe
donc les défis d'espèces pe est en train
de s'agrandir de jour en jour j'avais eu
le plaisir de vous en dire un mot une
autre occasion donc la maîtrise de ses
investissements me paraît nécessaire car
la france est aujourd'hui autonome
indépendante en matière énergétique
en tout cas on se console en énergie
électrique le suréquipement ne serait
pas forcément
exceptionnellement positif pour le pays
à partir du moment où le prix de revient
de ces énergies sont supérieurs à leur
prix de vente est de loin s'il s'agit de
pouvoir les exporter donc il faut garder
raison et avoir la foi d'une expertise
même temps un développement qui soit
rationnelle et non pas débridé ou
simplement un effet d'aubaine de
subventions et un effet de bulle donc
pragmatisme compétences et réalise a
rejoint la question sur le sur le
photovoltaïque
bien sûr que nous avons des équipes de
recherche et développement qui travaille
sur le photovoltaïque et notamment sur
le photovoltaïque de demain pour savoir
si un jour le fauteuil sera compétitif
bien entendu une travailler avec les
acteurs français notamment saint gobain
qui a construit des usines se trouvent
qu'ils ont construit une première usine
en allemagne et une deuxième
actuellement en asie et nous travaillons
sur les dans le domaine des technologies
avec les grands acteurs et des petites
neiges et en même temps on ne peut pas
attendre d'edf entreprise dans un
domaine compétitif entreprise efficace
parce qu'elle doit l'être encore prise
au service de nos concitoyens d'être
tirer le le financeur des des filières
marginal fusse-t-elle fusse-t-elle
d'origine locale donc oui pragmatisme
mouiller à la compétence oui l'énergie
sous toutes ses formes mais avec un
souci d'efficacité qui est qu'ici à
n'importe quelle entreprise y compris la
nôtre monsieur joël boyer sera nucléaire
je crois la filière française je crois
mais je me suis exprimé à abou dhabi
l'échec d'abou dhabi alors edf n'y est
pas pour grand chose je suis arrivé le
25 novembre encore une fois 2009 edf
n'était pas dans le tour de table prison
on m'a demandé de bien associer la
remise des prix le déplie était le 10
décembre
vous voyez j'ai rejoint le peloton le 2
décembre anniversaire d'austerlitz pour
une remise des plis vision plus tard on
entend huit jours rattraper le retard
pris pendant deux ans puisqu'il était
depuis deux ans qu'apple a été lancée
donc j'ai a essayé d'apporter quelques
correctifs mais un peu tardif et donc je
n'aurai pas la cruauté de d'expliquer
mon point de vue sur cet échec se serait
abuser ça manquerait d'élégance mais ça
me convainc du fait que mon la filière
française mérite mieux que ce pas une
organisation
je rejoins le rapport roussely donc dont
acte
voilà à peu près alors sur le taux de
disponibilité
bon il ya plusieurs sujets vaya le sujet
de la disponibilité de l'efficacité du
parc nucléaire existant
le parc nucléaire existant les 58
réacteurs existants ont le cas qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le taux de disponibilité
sur le taux moyen d'utilisation du parc
et puis il ya la production nucléaire
issue du cac tanner le taux de
disponibilité il y aura légèrement par
rapport à l'équipe
en même temps la production du parc
électronucléaire fera une autre a une
âme et une progression de 2 entre 5 et
7% attend les résultats définitifs et ce
sera probablement la première année dans
l'histoire d'edf ou les 58 sont des 58
réacteurs seront opérationnels au monde
et grand froid de noël
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir j'espère
s'ils rien eu des demandes d'ici là
parce que c'est une vraie prouesse
technique
ça veut dire que la production
électronucléaire s'est fortement
améliorée a maintenant sans que pour
autant le taux de disponibilité ce soit
formidablement parce que c'est un taux
moyen annuel et que on a intérêt à faire
les arrêts de tranche
au moment où elles sont le moins utile
c'est-à-dire pendant les périodes
creuses ou de poux pas les périodes de
pointe c'est-à-dire l'été l'automne
plutôt que l'hiver alors si on veut
optimiser de tôtes disponibilité on peut
très bien le faire au détriment de la
production nucléaire on peut très
bientôt disponible moyen annuel qui
s'améliorera fortement alors que la
production ne s'améliorera pas ou peut
être ça ça dépend du moment où on fait
des arrêts de tranche
il vaut mieux avoir les tranches en
opération au moment où on en a besoin
plutôt que les avoir eu en moyenne
annuelle donc oui on atteindra 85 % de
disponibilité à l'horizon dé cinq ans
qui viennent
oui on améliorera ce taux disponibilité
malgré les arrêts supplémentaires
nécessaires à l'extension de la durée de
vie des centrales
il faut bien voir que actuellement
rentrer dans la phase où on va essayer
d'obtenir les vingt ans d'extraction
durée de vie ça le meilleur
investissement qui sera jamais été
réalisé
mais ça veut dire qu'il faudra faire 10
arrêt plus long programme et est donc
l'amélioration du taux de disponibilité
malgré cela représente des prouesses
techniques extrêmement difficile à
réaliser
je suis très reconnaissant à l'équipe
est sous la responsabilité d'hervé
macheteau d'avoir déjà amorcé cette
première réorganisation qui permet dès
aujourd'hui de constater une émanation
de la production malgré des arrêts qui
sont plus importants que que ce qu'on
m'a traditionnellement pour préparer
justement les extensions du 28 donc
voilà le rôle le chantier qui est en
cours
il est en bonne voie rien n'est parfait
mais l'outil est en bon état de marche
et l'histoire le prouvera ou bien c'est
le pédant merci de nous avoir consacré
deux heures à cette audition on a des
collègues qui ont dû partir en séance
c'est une audition qui était très
intéressante qui a permis quand même
d'apporter beaucoup de réponses à ce que
les sénateurs peuvent
aux questions que sénateurs peuvent se
poser je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'avoir d'autres auditions je
veux remercier la presse aussi qui est
très nombreuses ici et qui vous entendu
vraisemblablement pour réparer peut-être
certaines interprétations tout comme
merci infiniment monsieur prix l'homme
merci mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de d'abord de votre présence
et et de votre soutien merci infiniment
vous venez de suivre l'audition d'henri
proglio sur l'avenir du nucléaire
français et sur la mise en oeuvre de la
loi nome sur la nouvelle organisation du
marché de l'électricité prochain rendez
vous à 16h30 pour la loi de finances
rectificative
bien sûr vous pouvez toujours retrouver
toutes les auditions et les séances en d
eau d sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée